Speaker 1: yesterday during Joe Biden's first
official State of the Union address. We saw the
most vile, deplorable, disgusting moment that
I've ever seen during any state of the Union.
And it was the moment that radical Republican
Congresswoman Lauren Boebert yelled out 13 of them
died on your watch or something like that. When
Joe Biden started talking about veterans who
have died in the line of service and that
includes, by the way, his deceased son,
who died of cancer and in the middle of
this moment, Lauren Boebert yells out,
and it is the most disgusting moment of any state
of the Union. I can remember I've been there.
Speaker 2: I've been in and out of Iraq and
Afghanistan over 40 times. These burn pits and
incinerate waste, the waste of war, medical and
hazardous material, jet fuel and so much more.
And they come home. Many of the world's
fittest and best trained warriors in the world
never the same headaches, numbness, dizziness, a
cancer that will put them in a flag draped coffin.
I know firsthand. One of those one of
those soldiers is my son, Major Beau Biden.
I don't know for sure if the burn pit that he
lived there, that is who was there in Iraq and
early on that in Kosovo is the cause of his brain
cancer, the disease of so many other troops.
But I am committed to find out everything we can.
Speaker 1: These are the most disgusting,
gross bad people. These aren't just bad
legislators, and there's some debate as to
whether both of the outbursts were Boebert. One
of them might have been Marjorie Taylor Greene.
It's not that they're both gross. They both
turned their backs on Biden when Biden walked in.
I wouldn't want Boebert or Greene
working at my local coffee shop
at my local library, teaching school kids. Being a
nurse, if I go into a hospital, they are the types
of gross bad people that I don't want anywhere
near me in any aspect of my life. And I mean,
before this, the most kind of disrespectful
State of the Union moment that I can recall
is when Republican Congressman Joe Wilson yelled,
You lie at Barack Obama. Let's review that.
Speaker 2: There are also those who claim that our
reform efforts would ensure illegal immigrants.
This, too, is false. The reforms, the reforms
I'm proposing would not apply to those who are
here illegally. Why?
Speaker 1:
So that was considered disrespectful, and it
was it is nothing compared to Lauren Boebert
yelling out when Joe Biden is literally
talking about his son who died,
Boebert tweeted about this, trying to make it seem
like her morals wouldn't allow her to sit idly by,
tweeting when Biden said flag draped coffins,
I couldn't stay silent. I told him directly.
He did it. He put 13 in there. Our heroic
servicemen and women deserve so much better
in a different era. A congresswoman shouting
and heckling the president at a state of the
Union while he's talking about not just U.S.
soldiers killed in action generally, but about
his own deceased son would be universally
condemned across the political spectrum,
starting with her caucus leader, and might even
be censured punished in some way. But these people
have support the people who like Boebert and
Green. They see this. Just look online. Go, go